[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
FRANK SCHILBACH:
Welcome to Lecture 17.
This lecture talks about
state-dependent preferences,
projection and attribution bias.
The plan for today is to talk
about preference changes.
So we're going to look at
different circumstances
in which people's
preferences, predictably
and sometimes unpredictably,
change over time.
That is to say, sometimes people
are hungry, tired or in pain,
and their preferences
for certain outcomes
may be determined by
that underlying state
of like hunger, for example.
Now, it's pretty clear that
people's preferences change
according to those states, as
in like when somebody is hungry,
they want different things.
They want to eat
different kinds of things
than when they're
not hungry and so on.
But people nonetheless
have trouble predicting
their preference changes.
That is to say, if
somebody is hungry,
they may have a
hard time predicting
how it feels when they're
not hungry and vice versa.
So notice that this lecture
is sort of a continuation
or natural continuation
of our lectures on beliefs
from before.
So before, we looked
at people trying
to learn about unknown
information around them,
and we looked at
various deviations
why people are
not able to learn.
Now we're going to look
at people trying to learn
or failing to learn at times
about their own preferences.
And one particular
case here is what's
called production bias,
which is people's lack of
or inadequate ability to
predict their own preferences,
in particular for
different states
of the world in the future.
I'm going to be more
specific about that,
but mostly, we're going
to talk about projection
bias and the paper by
Loewenstein et al., which
is in the readings.
We're going to talk very
briefly about attribution bias.
That's going to be
covered in recitation.
OK, so although not typically
emphasized in economics,
the simple and obvious fact
is that our preferences
change over time.
There are ways in which
our preferences change.
One is short-term
temporary fluctuations,
and you can call them sort of
state-dependent preferences.
You can call all
of what we're going
to talk about
state-dependent preferences.
Here, the state is a short-run
physiological or psychological
state, for example,
hunger, pain or the like,
or a psychological
state such as mood.
We're going to talk about
all of these in more detail.
Second, there are long-run
systematic changes.
These could be due to own
choices such as addiction.
So like if somebody has
been drinking alcohol
for the last 10
years, their utility
from drinking alcohol
or not drinking alcohol
is quite different from somebody
who has not been drinking ever.
The same is true for
smoking and the like.
Or it could be independent
of one's choices,
for example, aging.
So predictably,
people's preferences
change over time when
they're 20 years old
versus when they're
eight years old.
Notice that for
addiction, there's
also some short-run
temporary fluctuation
such as when people have just
smoked a cigarette versus not.
Their preferences for
an additional cigarette
might be quite different.
But then there's also
long-run systematic changes,
which is like if
somebody has been
smoking a lot during the
last 10 years versus not.
So smoking or
addiction in particular
has both short-term
and long-term
temporary and systematic
changes in people's preferences.
And then there's adaptation to
changes, which happens often
for big changes such
as standard of living
or small changes such
as mug ownership.
What's an example here?
For example, if people win the
lottery, they become happier.
They become actually a lot
happier very quickly, but then
that sort of reverts back to
like their previous standard
of time.
People, a lottery winner
seen like a few days later,
clearly are happier than people
who have not won the lottery,
but their increase in
happiness decreases over time.
So these are three
different types
of sets of preference changes.
You're going to mostly
focus in the lecture
today on, number one,
short-term, temporary
fluctuations.
Now, what am I
talking about here?
So one example here is hunger.
Now, studying hunger is
difficult in experiments
because it's unethical
to starve people.
And you could, of course,
find hungry people
and give them food.
That's in some sense
what was done once
in what's called the Minnesota
starvation experiment.
This is an experiment that
was motivated by the fact
that there was lots of soldiers
in the Second World War
from the US and Europe
and in many other places,
and these soldiers
had been starved
from the war for a long time.
And they came back from the
war to come back to the US,
and one simple
question was, well,
when you have people
who have starved,
have not eaten for a long time
or very little for a long time,
how do you best integrate
them into society,
or how do you best feed them.
Do you feed them very
quickly, like a lot,
or do you sort of gradually
increase their food take over
time?
So then the Army
did some experiments
with healthy volunteers such
as this guy here on the left.
And people were starved,
literally starved
by getting very little food
for a while, such that,
I think after a few weeks,
the guy would look like this.
And then the Army would look
at people's behavior over time.
They were mostly interested
in like once you have somebody
who has not eaten
for quite a while,
once you give them
more food, what's
happening to their
behavior and what's
the best way of doing that.
Coincidentally,
they also reported
what was happening in the
first part of the experiment
when people were
starved to start with.
And so as expected, people
get extremely focused on food
when they don't eat for a while.
They get really, really
interested in learning
about what's going
on with food and when
they get next food and so on.
But as it happens, it seems to
be that their preferences also
change in various other ways.
In particular, people
seem to lose interest
in lots of other activities.
It is reported
decreased alertness,
lack of self-control,
general apathy.
People are just sort of like
almost like a different person
when they are almost
starved compared
to when they have eaten a lot.
Here's some testimonies
from these soldiers.
One of them is, the acquisition
of food-related items
was a reasonable extension
of their heightened
interest in food.
So as we expect, people get
really interested in food.
Much less reasonable
was the buying
of old books, unnecessary
secondhand clothes, knickknacks
and other junk.
Often, after making
such purchases, which
could be afforded
only with sacrifice,
the man would be puzzled as to
why they had bought such more
or less useless articles.
So that's essentially
sort of saying
people got really interested
in certain purchases.
Their preferences towards
those kinds of purchases
seems to have changed.
They seem to have also
some preference reversal.
They seem to want
to buy some things
and then wonder afterwards
why they did so,
which all seems to be the
consequence of being really,
really hungry.
Then came the day when I
lost my will to activity.
I no longer cared to do
anything that required energy,
and days began to drag.
That seems to be in some
ways like a direct effect
of like having a
low caloric intake,
but really, people's
preferences towards physical
or any other activity seems to
have changed quite a bit due
to hunger.
And another one here--
there's nothing that can
hold my interest for long.
I wait for meal times.
And this is where people's
attention seemed to really
be lowered quite a bit, to the
extent that you think attention
affects people's preferences
and decision making
in various ways.
Again, hunger seems to have
this effect on people's choices.
Now, what's a more sort
of like a real world
example for you guys?
Well, that's shopping
on an empty stomach.
There's sort of a classic
study by Nisbett and Kanouse
from 1969, but there's sort
of other evidence later.
And the folk wisdom is that
shopping on an empty stomach
leads people to buy more, and
perhaps also more junk food.
Now, how do you study this?
Well, you can think
about different ways
in which you might do that.
You could sort of
induce people directly
to eat when they're
hungry versus not,
and there's various other ways
in which you could think about
like setting up experiments.
Now, one very
simple way in which
one could study this
issue is by just randomly
giving a sample of individuals
entering the supermarket
a candy bar.
It could be a candy bar.
It could be also a power
bar or just some other food.
And so now, essentially,
what you do then is,
you take a bunch of
people who go shopping.
And some of them might be
hungry and some might not be.
But then the ones that
are hungry in particular,
when they eat like a candy
bar or any other food,
they become less hungry.
And so then we have a treatment
tradition that's less hungry
and a control condition
who is not getting
any food who is more hungry.
And so then that
allows essentially
to look at variation in
whether people are currently
hungry while shopping.
Another thing one
could do is one
could vary the timing of the
last meal before shopping.
There you worry a little
bit, if that's not
experimentally induced,
that the people who
go shopping right after
having a meal versus not
might be quite different
in various other ways.
But you could, in
principle, also
experimentally induce that.
And then you can
monitor how much
and what kind of
food people buy.
So hungry people
tend to buy more.
They just simply buy more food.
They also more tellingly
buy more junk food.
So their preferences really
seem to be different.
To be clear, people tend to buy
more, not just sort of like,
say, I'm going to buy a Power
Bar or, for example, a banana
because I'm really hungry.
I'm going to bite it right
after I leave the store.
But they buy
significantly more, more
than can be explained by just
filling your immediate hunger.
And in particular, they also
seem to change the type of food
that they buy.
In particular, in this
case here, more junk food.
Here is kind of what
this then looks like.
The left guy is full.
He buys lots of lettuce,
diet water, and so on.
The guy on the right is hungry.
He buys all sorts of things,
a lot more as you can see,
and a lot of also
unhealthy food,
including tortilla chips,
cheese, sugar water, and so on.
So next time you go shopping,
you should sort of introspect
and see what your preferences
towards what you buy
have been affected.
Now, another thing you
can think about that
affects your preferences or
underlying state is your sleep.
When you're tired,
the whole world
seems different in various ways.
One example you can think
about is self-control.
And sleep deprivation
is associated
with lack of self-control.
There's sort of
this old literature
that says self-control
is a muscle that
replenishes overnight.
There's some issues
with this literature.
And there's some experiments
that might not necessarily
replicate.
But the idea that
lack of self-control
might be a consequence
of lack of sleep
seems very plausible
in various ways.
Notice that there
could also be causality
in the other direction.
Lack of self-control might
also be a cause of poor sleep.
Now, there's some
evidence that sleep
affects people's preferences.
When people are sleep-deprived,
they tend to gain weight.
Tired people engage more in
what's called cyberloafing.
They surf more on the internet.
There's also some evidence
that lack of sleep
might affect ethical behavior.
People cheat more
when they're tired.
And we have some evidence
in our experiment in India,
which I'm going to show
you in a little bit,
at the end of the semester,
that naps increase savings
and seem to reduce
people's present bias.
So really this is some
evidence of sleep affecting
people's time preferences.
Another example is Badger
et al. and addiction.
This is a very small study
with only 13 subjects.
So you might take all of what's
in there with a little bit
of a grain of salt. But I
think the underlying message
of the findings are correct.
So what did Badger et al. do?
They elicited
people's willingness
to pay for a second dose of
the heroin substitute, BUP.
These are heroin addicts
that are recovering.
And they tend to
have, often, cravings.
And BUP essentially helps
people not to relapse
and not to take heroin again.
And so, at regular intervals,
they get BUP doses.
Now it will be sort of unethical
to withhold people these doses.
But what the
experiment is doing--
and it's still ethically,
perhaps, tricky--
but what they were asking
for is people's willingness
to pay for a second dose of
BUP, the heroin substitute.
So all individuals
in the experiments
regularly receive their
single dose of BUP.
And then there's also an
additional dose they could get.
And then there was some
variation in the experiment.
What was the variation?
There was a variation in
the state of deprivation.
So people were either
asking all the questions
about our willingness to pay
for a second dose of BUP.
Everybody always
got the first dose.
But then there was some
variation in timing.
For some people, the
more deprived condition,
people were asked
about their willingness
to pay for a second
dose two hours
before the scheduled first dose.
And the less deprived
people were asked right
after the scheduled first dose.
Again, everybody's
getting a first dose.
And we're asking
about willingness
to pay for a second dose.
Some people are asked
about this two hours
before the scheduled first
dose, when they're really
sort of deprived and
craving, when they really
want their first dose.
And others are asked when
they're less deprived, right
after the scheduled first dose.
Notice that the second dose
is always held constant.
So everybody always
gets the first dose.
And the second dose is held
constant in the future,
at least in those
kinds of questions.
So really the willingness
to pay should not
depend on your current state.
In the future,
you're going to get
a second dose, which is
once you have already
gotten the first dose.
So whether you ask me like
two hours before or right
after your scheduled dose
should have more affect
on your willingness
to pay in the future
because that experience
is held fixed.
And you're always
getting the first dose.
Now, they are also asked
[INAUDIBLE],, in addition,
the timing of a
potential second dose.
So sometimes the second dose
was later on the same day
and sometimes the second dose
was during the next week.
Now, what do Badger et al. find?
They find that people's
willingness to pay
varies systematically with
the state and the delay.
What's the state here?
The state is the
state of deprivation,
whether people are more
deprived or less deprived.
And then the timing
is essentially
either about today
versus next week.
Now, the median willingness
to pay for the second dose
later today is $50
in the satiated state
and $75 in the deprived state.
And we're going to get back to
this how we think about this,
how we can explain this.
But basically the way we explain
this is that in the deprived
state, people's
willingness to pay
is higher because they really,
really want a first dose.
So people's willingness
to pay for the first dose
is high in the
deprived state and it's
lower in the satiated state
because they already have--
people's willingness to
pay for any additional dose
is high in the deprived state
because they haven't even
gotten the first dose.
And it's lower in
the satiated state.
But what people seem
to be doing now,
they seem to have a
hard time imagining
their utility in the future.
That is to say, in the future,
both people will be satiated.
So what's happening
here is that when
people are in the
deprived state,
they really, really want BUP.
And they're willing
to pay more than when
in the satiated state,
again, for the second dose
in the future.
Now, there's also some
evidence of willingness
to pay for the second
dose next week.
And again, people's
willingness to pay--
and so the previous
one was later today.
Now it's for the next week.
People's willingness to pay
in the deprived state is $60.
In the satiated state, it's $35.
So again, people's
willingness to pay
is higher in the deprived state.
That is to say, when
in the deprived state,
really, really, really
people want BUP.
And they cannot really
imagine that in the next week,
when they're satiated, they
will actually want BUP less.
To be clear, in both the first,
when the dose is later today
and when the dose
is next week, it'll
always be the case that
people have already
received the first dose.
And then the question
is always about what's
your willingness to pay
to receive a second dose.
So when they're in the future,
they will always be satiated.
But people in the
deprived state seem
to be reacting or seem to be
behaving as if, in the future,
they would also be in
the deprived state.
But of course people will
be in the satiated state.
So people seem to overestimate,
when they're in a deprived
state, how much they
would like the second dose
in the satiated
state in the future.
Now, here's another
example by Schelling.
And Schelling is a beautiful
writer in economics.
He's one of the best
writers that economics has.
Granted, there's lots of
bad writing in economics.
But if you want to read
some beautiful writing
by an economist,
Schelling has a bunch
of different books that
are really nice to read
and essays that are
really beautiful.
Now in his paper in
1984, he talks briefly
about a controversial
question, which
is the use of anesthesia
during childbirth.
And why is that controversial?
Well, anesthesia is
reducing the mother's pain
during childbirth.
But there's the potential
for some side effects.
And there's also the potential
that people's experience
is different.
And for both those
reasons, some people
argue that anesthesia
is not warranted
and decide not to do that.
Now, in many cases,
people's preferences
change predictably over time.
First, ex ante, before
the woman gives birth,
many women prefer not
to use anesthesia.
Once they are in
excruciating pain,
they request anesthesia
from their doctor.
And then, if they actually get
the anesthesia from the doctor
ex post, after the child is
born, they regret their choice.
They say, I wish I
hadn't gotten anesthesia.
Now, that pattern
holds even for women
who have given birth before.
And it leads to a bunch
of ethical dilemmas
and legal issues.
For example, to which patient is
a physician obligated, the one
asking for anesthesia or the one
who asked that it be withheld?
The person told the
doctor, I really,
really do not want anesthesia.
Even if I ask you later, please
do not give me anesthesia.
But then, of course, the
person that yells at the doctor
and says, I really,
really want anesthesia.
Give me anesthesia right now.
And so there's essentially
preference reversals.
People seem to want
different things
at different points in time.
And the doctor can only make
one of these two people happy.
And so no matter what
the doctor does, either
if the person gives the person
anesthesia, then person number
2 in my list here above
is going to be happy,
but person number 1 and
person number 3 are unhappy.
Or the person withholds
anesthesia and then person
number 2 is unhappy.
So either way, the doctor cannot
satisfy these different selves
over time.
Now, can the physician
enter a contract
with a patient ex ante, before?
Is it possible to have a
legally binding contract here
when he or she says, I'm not
going to give any anesthesia,
and you told me so?
Do we want policies that
make such contracts possible?
Is that a desirable thing to do?
Is it a legally
required thing to do?
Potentially impossible
to require this legally.
I'm not sure.
But the point here
really is that there
is some misprediction
going on here.
Ex ante, the person says, well,
if I'm in pain, I will be fine.
I'm not going to
need anesthesia.
But then, of course, when the
person is actually in pain,
the person wants anesthesia.
So essentially people seem to
mispredict their preferences
when they're in pain.
Then that leads to all
sorts of trouble here.
I really recommend
to read the paper
by Schelling that's
on the course website
if you want to sort think
about this a little bit more.
Now, so far, we talked
about that preferences
change predictably due to
changes in underlying states.
Now, one of those states, it
would be like pain, hunger,
sleep, and so on.
Now, there's an
additional stylized fact
just that people make systematic
mistakes at predicting
preference changes.
So not only is it that your
preferences are different when
you're tired versus
not, but people are also
systematically mispredicting
that preference change.
Now, what is projection bias?
To be clear, it's the fact that
people underappreciate changes
in their preferences, projecting
their current preferences
onto future preferences.
So projection bias, to
be clear, is not just
some random prediction
but a prediction
with a systematic direction.
So people seem to understand the
direction of preference change
but not the magnitude.
That is to say, when
people are hungry and think
about how it's going to
feel when they're not hungry
anymore, they kind of understand
that eventually they will not
be hungry and that maybe,
suppose you're really hungry
and you really
want potato chips,
you sort of understand
that you don't really
want that many potato
chips when you're full.
Nevertheless, when
people are hungry,
they buy 10 bags of potato
chips as if they were hungry
at least for like
half of their life,
even though they're going to be
hungry for the next hour or two
because then they're going to
go home and go eat and so on.
So people seem to
understand the direction
of people's preferences
but not the magnitude.
Now the underappreciation
of the effects
of hunger on
preferences is perhaps
not the most economically
important part
of projection bias or the
most important application.
But there two reasons to
consider this evidence.
But one, it's perhaps
the clearest evidence
of projection bias.
Second, people have
lots of experience
with changes in their
levels of hunger.
So any misprediction isn't
due to the lack of opportunity
to learn, really, when you
should have probably learned
this over time.
For some other instances--
this is only, for
example, if you
have lots of physical pain, or
for childbirth, for example,
you might say, well, that
seems to be sometimes
even "one in a
lifetime" experience,
where really it's sort of
understandable that people
mispredict their
preferences when
they are in excruciating pain.
But that's understandable
because you
haven't experienced it before.
And even for somebody, a mother
who has given birth to a child
before, that mother might just
misremember to some degree.
But when it comes
to hunger, people
have been hungry so many
times, and full, and so on.
So really you had lots
and lots of opportunities
to learn what your preferences
are when you're hungry
versus not.
So really it shouldn't be about
a lack of opportunity to learn.
Now, people buy more
on an empty stomach.
That can be interpreted as a
manifestation of projection
bias.
Hungry people act as if
their future taste for food
will reflect the current
hunger at least to some degree,
or more so than
it actually does.
But it's not completely clean
evidence of projection bias,
because there could be
always other things going on.
For example, if
you're really hungry,
some things might be
more salient to you.
And there you might
buy certain things
more because you pay more
attention, for example,
to potato chips and really
sort of learn how exciting
potato chips are and so on.
But let's just go
with hunger for now.
There's lots of other evidence
of projection bias in addition
to the hunger example.
Now remember the paper that
we discussed on food choices
by Read and van Leeuwen.
This is the paper
where office workers
are asked to choose
between a healthy snack
and an unhealthy snack.
Now, so far, we had looked at
this as a piece of evidence
for present bias.
We were looking at when
people are choosing
for the present
right now versus when
they choose for the future.
Do people make more
unhealthy choices
when they choose
for the president?
That is to say the
stylized fact that we
found was that when people are
choosing snacks for the future,
they were quite likely
to choose healthy snacks.
You choose salad for the future
as your snack in the afternoon.
And then, you ask again,
right now or today,
what would you like, people
seem to switch their preferences
towards unhealthy snacks.
They'd rather have,
like, chocolates.
And so we interpreted
that, at the time,
as evidence of present bias.
And surely it seems like that
is evidence of present bias.
Now, in addition, now, we're
going to consider variation
in the timing of those choices.
So some people were asked
when they were hungry,
late in the afternoon.
Others were asked when they were
satiated or arguably satiated,
immediately after lunch.
And then the snacks were
to be received in one week.
So that's held
constant, the timing.
Otherwise the timing
is held constant.
So we're always going to
look at choices for snacks
to be received in one week.
In some of the cases,
the snacks were
to be received when people were
hungry or likely hungry, late
in the afternoon.
In some other
cases, the snacks we
received when people
were satiated,
immediately after lunch.
OK, so there's like
four cases here.
There's the timing of choice.
Either people are asked if
they're hungry versus not.
And then the timing
of the receipt
of their snack, which is when
they were hungry versus not.
And the question now is,
are hungry people now
good or bad at predicting
their preferences when they're
satiated, and are satiated
people good or bad
at predicting their preferences
when they're hungry,
in the different state?
So we're going to
interpret here--
so here's a table from Read and
van Leeuwen, table number 1.
It's a bit of a sort
of confusing table
for no good reason.
Let me just walk you very
quickly through that table.
So the rows are
the current hunger
and the columns
are future hunger.
So the first row
is when people were
asked when they were hungry.
So this is late
in the afternoon.
The second row is people were
asked when they were satiated.
That's like right after lunch.
And then the columns are--
again, remember, all of the
choices are for next week.
So the first column is choices
for when people were hungry.
That's late in the afternoon.
And the second column is
when people were satiated.
That's right after lunch.
Remember, again, all
choices are for next week,
so for one week in the future.
Now, we can interpret, now,
the main diagonal of this table
as reflecting people's
true preferences.
That is to say, here's
no projection bias.
People are asked, when hungry,
to predict what they wanted
or to say what they
wanted in the future, when
they were likely going
to be hungry as well.
That is to say, 78% of people
are choosing an unhealthy snack
for the future when
they're hungry-- so
that's in the late afternoon--
for the future case
when they're in
the late afternoon.
In contrast, only 26% of people
choose the unhealthy snack when
they're satiated-- that
is right after lunch--
for when the snack will
be delivered in one week,
right after lunch.
So there's no
projection bias here.
Because essentially this
underlying state, hunger,
is held constant.
Hungry people predicting
for when they're hungry
or asking what they want when
they're hungry, 78% of people
think they want unhealthy stuff.
And again, satiated
people, 26% of people
say they want unhealthy stuff.
So 74% of people say they want
the healthy snack, in contrast,
when they're satiated.
So again, that's
what's written here.
Late in the afternoon,
when people are hungry,
78% of people choose
the unhealthy snack
for the late afternoon
when they will be hungry.
Immediately after lunch, when
they're satiated, 26% of people
choose the unhealthy
snack for immediately
after lunch when they
will be satiated.
Now, then what we see
here is the entries
that are off the main diagonal.
Those data fit the pattern
of projection bias.
Now what do I mean by that?
Let's look first at
people who are hungry
but expect to be satiated.
That is the first row here.
Current hunger is hungry.
That's essentially people are
asked late in the afternoon.
Or think about this as
being likely hungry.
And they're ask about
why what do they
want when they're satiated?
That is right after lunch.
Now, remember, when people
were satiated, 26% of people
said they wanted
an unhealthy snack.
Now, when people are
hungry, 42% of people
say they want an
unhealthy snack.
So that fraction is higher.
So that is very much consistent
with projection bias,
the reason being that, when
people are hungry and say what
they want for themselves
in the hungry state,
well, 78% of people say they
want the unhealthy snack.
If people did not have
any projection bias,
they really should be
saying 26% if you believe
that satiated people
know best what they want
when they will be satiated.
Instead, 42%, a higher
fraction of people,
say they want an unhealthy
snack when predicting
or when answering while
they're hungry for when
they would be satiated.
So people seem to understand the
direction in which their tastes
change as they become satiated,
but they underestimate
the magnitude of this change.
Similarly, people who are
currently satiated but expect
to be hungry underestimate
the effect of hunger
on their preferences
for unhealthy snacks.
Remember, hungry people, when
they choose for next week
when they will be
hungry, 78% of people
say they want the
unhealthy snack.
Now, in contrast, when they're
satiated, 56% of people
choose the unhealthy snack.
So again, that
fraction now deviates
from the fraction when
people are hungry,
which is, again, consistent
with people understand
the direction in which tastes
change as they become hungry,
but they underestimate the
magnitude of this change.
So satiated people think that
when they're in the future,
hungry, they will behave
at least a little bit
like as if they were satiated.
And hungry people seem to
think that, when they're
satiated in the
future, they will still
behave as if they were hungry.
Notice that this
misprediction is partial.
So again, both the 42%
is in between the 26%
and the 42% is in between
the 26% and the 78%.
And again, the 56% is
between the 26% and the 78%.
So there's essentially some
partial misprediction going on
here.
Now, let me show you a number
of other examples of projection
bias.
And then I'm going to write
down a little model that
sort of captures this
information or the information
that's here.
So another example
is catalog orders.
This is Conlin et al.
Imagine there's a cold evening.
It's really cold outside.
Maybe you were just
outside and so on,
and then you are
online shopping.
Notice that in Conlin
et al., really, it's
catalog orders and
not online shopping
because online shopping didn't
quite exist at the time.
But in any case, imagine you
buy, online, a warm jacket.
And again, it's
really cold right now.
You really wish you
had a warm jacket.
But then, when the
warm jacket arrives,
its 30 degrees warmer
when that happens.
Now, that could or could not
be, potentially, a mistake.
In particular, if it's
an unusually cold day,
if people have
projection bias, they
might sort of think that,
well, right now they really
need a warm jacket.
And they can't even
imagine that they might not
need this warm jacket anymore
in a few days from when
it actually arrives
from the order.
And so the hypothesis
is that projection bias
leads to an increase in
purchases of cold-weather items
on cold-weather days.
And not only that,
but controlling
for receive-day
temperature, the likelihood
of returning a
cold-weather object
is higher when the day
of ordering was cold.
So not only people are buying
more cold-weather items
on cold-weather days--
that seems very reasonable.
Because you might just say, I
always wanted a jacket anyway.
It's really cold.
And that just reminds me
that I really need one.
Or, for example, it's really
rainy and you buy an umbrella.
Because again, you
just remembered
that you really needed
one or that you forgot it
somewhere and so on.
The telling part here
is that the likelihood
of returning the
cold-weather object
is higher when the day
of ordering was cold.
And that's very much consistent
with projection bias.
People, on
cold-weather days, act
as if the future were only
full of cold-weather days.
And therefore their
preferences would be such
that they would always
want to put weather items.
Or put differently, people
act as if their preferences
for cold-weather items-- they
really want a warm jacket--
would not change even
if, in the future,
there will be warm days.
Notice that, in some of
this evidence, what's
hard to distinguish is
predicting people's preferences
change in the future versus
predicting future states.
So if somebody predicted that
it's going to be cold forever,
who would act in
the exact same way
as if you predicted that your
preferences are such that you
always want warm jackets,
you're always going to be cold.
Now, projection bias
is about the latter.
It's about people's preferences.
But often it's actually
hard to separate predictions
of probabilities
of how likely it
is that it's going to
be cold in the future
from predictions of
people's utility.
Another example is car purchases
on Sunday versus radio or days
imagine it's a nice,
sunny day and you
go car shopping as you do it.
And the car dealer
offers you an Audi TT.
You know, "Why, I guess I
never thought of the Audi TT."
You go for a test drive.
And the wind rips
through your hair.
It's really sunny and great.
And having this car during a
sunny day is really amazing.
So you would love to
buy a car like this.
Why not?
Imagine, in contrast, car
purchases on an icy day.
Imagine you're car shopping
around the time of a freak
snowstorm.
You kind of wanted
to have a car,
and somehow it's a snowstorm
when you go car shopping.
Now, the car dealer says, how
about this grand Jeep Grand
Cherokee.
And you might say, well,
I guess I never thought
of the Jeep Grand Cherokee.
Why not try it?
You go for a test drive and you
gain traction on the black ice
and you jump the curb with ease.
It's just amazing.
Now, you might just say, well,
I would love a car like this.
Now, what people
seem to be forgetting
in both of these examples
is that it might just
happen to be a really bad snow
day on that particular day.
Or it might have just
been really sunny
on that particular day.
And things like
change over time.
And people might not understand
that their preferences
for the Audi versus
the Jeep might change
with the weather over time.
And that's exactly what
Busse et al. are looking at.
They're looking at how does
weather impact automobile
purchases.
And in particular the
classical prediction
is that the weather, on
the day of a car purchase,
should have no influence
on the type of car bought.
So now what Busse et al. look
at is do idiosyncratic weather
conditions, controlling for time
of year and predict car sales
and then, in particular,
also returns of those cars.
And they look at
two types of cars,
in particular
convertibles and then
they look at four-wheel
drives like the Jeep
that I just showed you.
And the key part here is to
look at idiosyncratic weather
conditions.
That is to say, controlling
for time of the year.
Suppose it's an unusually warm
and unusually cold or icy day.
Does that predict people's
car sales or purchases
and particularly also the
returns of those cars?
Now, the buying patterns
are very much consistent
with projection bias.
People buy more convertibles
on good-weather days
and more four-wheel drives
on bad-weather days.
And again, that
evidence by itself
is not necessarily
projection bias.
It could just be a good-weather
day and you kind of always
wanted to buy a really
nice car, and therefore
you just do it on
a good-weather day.
But people are also more likely
to return their convertible
if they bought it in
the good-weather day.
And they're likely to return
their four-wheel drive if they
bought it on a bad-weather day.
And that's very much
consistent with evidence
of projection bias.
On a good-weather day,
you think your convertible
is going to be amazing forever.
You're going to love driving.
And even if it's
going to be raining,
it's going to be amazing.
But of course, if it's
raining, that convertible
is really not a car
that you want to have.
Or is really cold outside,
that's really not a great car
to have.
Similarly, if you have
a four-wheel drive
and it's really warm
and nice outside,
you'd probably much rather have
a lighter car or potentially
even a convertible.
Now, one important
question here is now,
in any of the behavioral
biases that we
discussed is how does the
market react to such behavior.
So one tricky part here is that
you want to be kind of careful.
So on one hand, you
might say, well,
let's exploit this
kind of behavior.
And I think that's right.
You might get people to
purchase stuff that they
don't necessarily want.
And surely that's
happening in some cases.
But to the extent that people
can just return these items,
that's actually not
necessarily a great idea.
And particularly if
you're a car salesperson
and you sell people stuff
and then you just come back
and you have to deal with
them, and they're unhappy,
and maybe, then, at
the end of the day,
you just return the car and
actually don't buy anything
eventually because
they're unhappy,
that's really not great for you.
Plus it wastes a lot
of time and effort.
On the other hand,
sometimes people
might just not return things.
And they might just get
stuck with their car
and just leave it at that.
And then it might be a good
idea to exploit this behavior,
particularly on a
good-weather day,
you might want to try to
sell people convertibles.
Another thing you could
potentially exploit
is essentially people just
have higher willingness to pay.
Suppose somebody
really, really wants
to buy a convertible anyway,
regardless of the weather.
But on a good-weather day,
their willingness to pay
might be higher.
And so you might be able to sell
them additional stuff for you
might be able to sell them maybe
a nicer version of the car,
which probably they're
not going to return.
Because once they have it,
they're just going to keep it.
And so you might want to exploit
that if you are a company.
There might also be some agency
issues within the sales shop,
which is like if the salesperson
really wants to sell things
and is incentivized
to sell things,
and that's regardless
of the returns,
then you might get
into situations where,
on sunny days, lots of
convertibles are being sold
but they're all being returned.
So if you are a
company, you kind of
want to set the incentives right
that the car salesman gets only
rewarded for stuff that's not
returned because it precisely
gets you things that will not
make you happy or profitable
in the long run.
Now, there's another--
so as a customer,
now, how might you take
advantage of production bias?
Well, there's an
article here that you
can look at that argues
that winter is the best
time to buy a convertible.
And so the reason is,
of course, convertibles
are often cheaper
in winter in part
because the car dealer might
have storage costs, the like.
So the convertible
is actually cheaper.
Or just because people
are taking advantage
of in the summer when they
really want convertibles.
Now, you might say,
well, let's just buy
a convertible in the winter.
And I think that's,
in principle, right
if you have the time to
wait until the summer
or have a long time horizon.
Now, you want to be
a little bit careful
with exploiting these
market conditions
as a classical agent,
which is manifested
by some of my
colleagues who shall
be unnamed who wanted to
buy a convertible sometime
in the summer.
They got really excited
about the convertible.
But then they realized,
well, winter is actually
the time to buy a
convertible because it's
going to be cheaper.
So then they decided,
well, let's just
wait until the winter and
then buy the convertible then.
Of course, what then
unfortunately happened--
or maybe fortunately.
It depends on the perspective.
Once winter arrived,
they actually
didn't want a
convertible anymore.
Because a convertible in
the winter is really not
a lot of fun.
So projection bias
perhaps also kicked in
with my colleagues,
where they then perhaps
should have just
bought the convertible
and then predicted that, in the
summer, they really wanted it.
But instead they did buy it.
Because wants a
convertible in the winter?
So when exploiting behavioral
biases from others,
you want to be careful that you
may be affected by it yourself.
Let me give you one
last example, which
is this example by Van
Boven and Loewenstein,
which is about thirst.
Here, visitors are asked
before or after vigorous
cardiovascular workouts--
so people who are going
to the gym--
to complete a short survey.
And the survey was as follows.
Imagine that three vacationers
in Colorado this past August
embarked on a short 6-mile hike.
As the day wore
on, they realized
that they were hopelessly lost.
Worse, because they had packed
lightly for a short hike,
they had not carried much
in the way of food or water.
And what people were
asked, then, about-- and so
they were essentially
given this story.
And then they were asked
to do the following.
In the space below, please
take the perspective of one
of the three hikers and
describe your situation--
how you got into it,
how you feel now,
both physically and mentally,
and what you are hoping
will happen."
And now what happens and what
the evidence of Van Boven
and Loewenstein says is that
thirsty subjects have way more
empathy for others' thirst.
So when you look at
the different outcomes,
before and after exercising--
remember, after exercising
is when people are thirsty--
thirst was mentioned
before hunger in the assay,
for thirsty people much more.
Thirst was unpleasant.
For hikers, it was
mentioned much more.
Hikers would regret
not packing water.
Thirst more unpleasant
for the self.
Oneself would regret
more not packing water.
So all of these
items that are sort
of like thirst-related,
people, when
they were thirsty
after exercising
were way more
focused on than not.
So it is as if people have
projection bias in the sense
people understand much more
that the condition of thirst
is really bad when
they're thirsty
compared to when they are not.
OK, so let me take stock
of what we discussed.
So I showed you some
evidence of projection bias
for many short-run
changes in preferences,
and at least for some of them.
There's hunger, thirst, pain,
sleep, weather, addiction.
There's other evidence as well--
arousal, anger, sadness,
and so on-- when
people aren't
certain states, they
have trouble to predict their
preferences when they're not
in that state.
Now, one key
question that I don't
have a great answer for you
is why do people not learn?
People have had
lots of experience
with a lot of these
changes, in particular
when you think about sleep
or hunger or the like.
But even for addiction,
when people just
have smoked a cigarette versus
not, that happens all the time.
So they really should
have learned, over time,
to predict their preference.
So the misprediction is
really not due to a lack
of opportunity to learn.
Yet people really seem
to believe, all the time,
that this time is different,
over and over again.
So I think that's just
a very deep cognitive
bias in some ways
in the sense of,
when people are affected
by certain visceral
or other aspects that
affect their preferences,
it's really hard to
imagine how they might feel
when that visceral influence
is not at play anymore
in the future.
In addition to people
underestimating
short-run changes
in preferences,
people also underestimate
adaptation to long-run changes.
So Dan Gilbert, if
you're interested,
has very nice work,
including a book
called Stumbling on Happiness.
And he gives many examples
of the underestimation
of adaptation, which
they call immune neglect.
And so one example is how does
a positive or negative tenure
decision affect well-being?
And so they ask current
assistant professors
at the University of
Texas to forecast.
And then they ask, as
well, former University
of Texas assistant
professors to recall.
And as a current assistant
professor like myself,
if you forecast, if there's
a negative tenure decision,
life will be terrible.
And how are we ever going to
live after being denied tenure?
And so when you look at
what's actually happening,
professors seem to be relatively
accurate in predicting
the immediate impact
of the tenure decision,
but they overestimated
the long-run impact.
That is to say, in
fact, immediately
after being denied
tenure, people
are maybe arguably
or understandably
disappointed and unhappy.
But over time, the long run
effect is much less severe.
People seem to adjust
to their circumstances.
In the medium and
long run, people
are almost as happy
as if not as happy
as if they had gotten tenure.
So there's actually not
much of a long-run effect.
Yet people seem to
mispredict the effect.
They really seem to
think, in the short run,
the effect will be really bad.
And that bad effect
will last forever.
So people seem to essentially
sort of understand
there's a psychological
immune system to bad events.
People recover from negative
shocks quite well over time.
But people seem to mispredict
this recovery, which
which again is what's
called immune neglect.
There's similar misprediction
for other life events
such as paraplegia or
lottery wins, so for very
negative and positive events.
People seem to misunderstand
that, again, in the short run,
there's usually a
pretty large decrease
or increase in people's
happiness and life
satisfaction.
But people tend to recover
from that quite well over time.
But in their
prediction, people seem
to mispredict that adjustment.
People seem to think that the
bad effects on happiness--
or bad or good effects
and happiness--
would persist forever.
Let me now show you a simple
model of projection bias
by Loewenstein et al.
that formalizes some
of the intuitions
that we discussed so far.
So suppose true
utility at time t
depends on both
consumption ct at time t
and the state st at the time t.
So it's u of ct
st. The state could
be anything that affects utility
from consumption, ranging
from the level of
hunger or addiction,
whether somebody had
just smoked versus not
or whether somebody has just
gotten some BUP dose or not,
or past consumption, et cetera,
whether somebody is tired,
and so on.
Now, the prediction at time t
of future utility at the time
tower larger than t
from assuming the c tau
and state as tau is u
hat of c tau as tau.
And that equals 1
minus alpha times u
of c tau as tau plus
alpha times u of c tau st.
Now, what is this expression?
Well, if you look at the
first part, u of c tau
s tau, that is the
correct future utility
at time tau from consuming
c tau in state tau.
So if alpha was 0, then this
term here would go away,
this term is just 1.
So that is essentially
a correct prediction.
So there is no production bias.
The person has
rational expectation
about their future utility
at time tau of utility c
tau in state s tau.
Now, if alpha is not
zero, then there's
this additional term here.
So this is the weighted
average of alpha weights
for this other term
here, which we're going
to talk about in a second.
And 1 minus alpha, the
correct utility of consuming
c tau in state s tau.
Now, what is this
other term here?
Well, the person
gets c tau correctly,
so the consumption is right
but the state is wrong.
And what state is
the person using
to predict their future utility?
Well, it's using st,
the current state.
So the person is essentially
using their current state
to some degree to predict
their future utility instead
of the future state as tau.
Now, notice that if st
and s tau is the same,
then there's no problem here.
There's going to be
no misprediction.
So it better be the
case that the states st
and s tau are different.
For example, a hungry person
would mispredict that utility
from not being hungry.
So the utility from not being
hungry would be this part.
The person is hungry right now
at time t if st equals hungry.
The person would predict
the future utility even
when they're not hungry,
thinking that they will always
be hungry in the future.
So alpha in between 0 and 1 is
the degree of projection bias.
So just to give you
more detail, the person
predicts how she'd
feel about consuming c
tau in the future partially
at least by how she'd
feel about consuming it now.
That's what the parameter
alpha is measuring.
Alpha between 0 and
1-- it could be 0.
It could be 1--
is the degree of
projection bias.
So alpha equals 0 is
correct understanding
of future utility.
That's essentially
no projection bias.
That's rational expectations.
Alpha equals 1 is
full projection bias.
That's a person who
thinks, essentially,
their future state
will always be
their current state,
which, of course, is not
necessarily true.
So now that person will optimize
according to a perceived
future preferences.
You had c tau, s
tau, and I'm going
to assume for now is an
exponential discounter.
That's, of course, you
could relax that easily.
And, in fact, in
some of the problem
sets from previous years
and from this year,
that will be, in fact, relaxed.
Now let me give you a very
simple example with hunger.
Again, the problem set this
year and past problem sets
give you quite a few
other additional examples
that you can study.
So suppose there are two states.
The state is either hungry
or not hungry, H or N.
And the consumption ct is
over burgers and money.
So u of ct where ct is the
number of burgers and money
that the person has.
And state H is 5 times
the number of burgers
that the person eats plus
the remaining money that's
left to spend on other things.
The utility of ct and when
the person is not hungry
is 1 times the number of burgers
plus the money that's left.
Now what does that imply?
Well, it implies that she's
willing to pay $5 for a burger
when hungry and $1 when full.
How do we know that?
Well, we know that because
in the first case when
the person is hungry,
each burger gives 5 utils,
and each dollar gets 1 util.
So the exchange rate between
burgers and utils is 5.
So the person is going
to pay $5 per burger.
In the second case,
the exchange trade
between utility from burgers
and utility from dollars is 1.
So the person is willing
to pay $1 for a burger.
Now suppose alpha is 3/4.
Again, remember alpha is the
degree of projection bias.
I'm going to go
back and show you.
Alpha is this parameter here.
Alpha is the degree
of projection bias,
so the degree of misprediction.
So suppose in our example
here alpha equals 3/4,
and the person is
not hungry right now.
What is their willingness
to pay for a burger
tonight when she'll be hungry?
So if the person is
not hungry right now,
her correct utility
or willingness
to pay for a burger is $1.
We just established
that already.
She's full.
And the correct utility for
willingness to pay for a burger
tonight when she'll
be hungry is $5.
Now her projection bias is 3/4.
So essentially she puts 3/4 of
a weight on her current state
and 1/4 on the full state.
Well, 3/4 times 1
plus 1/4 times 5
or going essentially 3/4
between a difference of 4
is essentially 3.
So the person
essentially will think
that their future willingness to
pay is $2 for a burger tonight.
Or put differently, if she
thinks she only wants like--
her willingness to pay will
only be $2 for a burger tonight,
if she orders for
a burger tonight
and the burger
costs like $3 or $4,
she will not be
willing to do that.
Now just to be very clear, so
the person only essentially--
if alpha equals
3/4, the person only
incorporates 1/4 of
the preference change
from being full versus
hungry in the future.
So that is to say there's a
difference of $4 between $1
and $5, and she only takes into
account 1/4 of that $4, which
is $1.
So willingness to pay
is 1 plus 1 equals 2.
You can also write
this down here
instead of using the
formula from the equation
from before, which essentially
is 3/4, which is, again,
alpha times utility
using the current state,
and 1/4 using the
correct utility, which
is the future state.
Once you sort of
calculate that, she
would be willing to pay
at most $2 for a burger.
So potentially she's
making a mistake.
And so again in
the problem set you
will have more
examples and questions
that allows you to practice
with this level model.
Now, why should you care
about projection bias?
I showed you pretty
good evidence
of projection bias in many
settings in the sense of saying
we think projection bias really
exists and we think projection
bias might be quite important.
Sorry.
It might be relevant in
explaining people's behavior
in those settings.
Now, the consequences
in those settings
is relatively unimportant.
For example, in car purchases
if rich people buy convertibles
and then sort of return
their convertibles,
the loss from that is
not particularly large.
Maybe there's some
redistribution across people.
Similarly, the
catalog orders, people
might purchase too many
things and return them.
Really, the consequences
are not that large,
and the actions are
often reversible.
So why should we then care
about projection bias?
Well, there's at least two
really important applications
that we're going to talk about
for a little bit that really
could matter quite a lot.
One is addiction,
which is people
mispredict the
utility from becoming
addicted in the future.
Second is depression and hope.
When people are
depressed, they might
mispredict how they feel when
they're not depressed anymore.
Some might argue that
marriage and relationships are
quite important or projection
bias might be quite important.
Particularly when
people have fights,
they might want to get
divorced very quickly.
They might sort
of do rash things
about getting married
really quickly
or try to get a
divorce very quickly.
And, in fact, there are some
laws that often prevent that.
People need to actually have
some cool-down period for a few
days where they
have to sort of--
if one wants to get
married, for example,
you have to get a license,
and it takes a few days,
and only then you
can get married.
The same is true for a divorce,
at least in some places.
Perhaps that's because people
suffer from projection bias
sometimes.
And when they're really mad
at somebody or something
really bad happens between
them or something really great
happened between
them, they might not
be able to predict that their
preferences and their views
towards the other person
might change over time.
But let me tell you now a
little bit about addiction
and depression and hope.
So first addiction, and
that's the main applications
we're going to discuss.
So projection bias might
be important for people's
initiation when people are
starting to take drugs.
So here let's define
the relevant state
as the person's
level of addiction.
So how much has the person
consumed of cigarettes
in the last month or year?
In an unaddicted state,
cigarettes are really not
that hard to resist, right?
If somebody has
never smoked before,
cigarettes are really
not that attractive.
Same is true also for
alcohol, for example.
In an unaddicted-- so
in an addicted state,
however, it's very hard
to resist cigarettes.
If you have smoked
a lot recently,
you really, really would like
to smoke on any given day.
Now, the unaddicted
person might sort of
think that experimenting
with cigarettes is fun
but does not want
to get addicted
for the rest of her life.
It's sort of fun to
do it for a while,
but really then you want
to stop because being
addicted for the rest of
your life is really bad.
You might get really bad health
consequences, for instance.
And that might give
you some false--
if you sort of have
projection bias,
you might have some
false sense of control.
If you project your current
nonaddictive preferences
into the future, you might
think that you can stop smoking
or taking drugs if necessary.
And so then the person might
try cigarettes, get addicted,
and consume much of your life.
Perhaps she wouldn't do so
if she knew she could quit.
That's essentially to say if
you're not addicted right now,
you might predict
that it's going to be
always easy to stop smoking.
And, in fact, right
now it is really easy
to stop smoking or resisting.
But the person might mispredict
that this will always
be the case in the future
even once she is addicted
and once she has
smoked a lot because
for the nonaddicted person,
it's really hard to imagine
that it might be even harder
to resist in the future.
In addition, there are
quitting and restarting
cycles that are very common
when it comes to addiction.
So addicts often
express a desire
to stop using
substances permanently
but are unable to
follow through.
That's not surprising,
and we've kind of
thought about this before.
And quasi hyperbolic
discounting can essentially
predict that as well.
Short-term abstention
in addiction
is common while long-term
abstention is rare.
So in 2000, for
example, 41% of smokers
stopped for at least one day
trying to quit, but only 4.7%
successfully abstained for
more than three months.
That doesn't really seem like
quasi hyperbolic discounting.
So you wouldn't go through
a pointless short-term pain
and then not follow
through if [INAUDIBLE]
quasi hyperbolic discounting.
The reason being in particular
that withdrawal symptoms
tend to be, on
average, strongest
at the start of a quit attempt.
So hyperbolic discounting
would not sort of
go over this really difficult
pain in the short run
if you don't follow through
because it's essentially
short-run pain.
And then three, recidivism
rates are especially high when
addicts are exposed to
occasional cues related
to past consumption.
So treatment programs, in
fact, advise recovering addicts
to move to new locations
and to avoid places
when previous
consumption took place.
So let's sort of go
through these one by one
and try to see whether,
particularly in two and three,
whether we can explain
those using projection bias.
So now let's define the state
as the strength of cravings
at the moment, and suppose
this varies randomly
or with exposure to cues.
How do you explain the
starting a quit attempt?
Well, suppose an addict is
currently consuming regularly.
She experiences
periods of low cravings
when it's easy to resist.
That's like when the person has
just smoked, cravings are low,
and it's easy to resist.
So then the person
might think, well, it'll
always be easy to
resist, so she thinks
it's worth trying to quit and
starts the quitting attempt.
Now, how do we explain
then how people
abandon the quit attempt?
Well, suppose the addict is
currently on a quit attempt.
Something triggers strong
cravings, which might just
be over time you get
cravings or maybe the person
might just be
exposed to some cues.
So then the person
feels it's really hard
to resist the drugs,
and in particular, she
thinks drugs will always be
hard to resist because currently
she's craving a lot,
and you can't even
imagine that it might be--
that that craving
might stop over time.
So she thinks the quit attempt
is impossible to carry through,
and so she abandons it.
So that way projection
bias can both explain
why the person starts
the quit attempt
but also why the person
does not follow through.
I'm sorry.
Give me a second.
How do we think
about the recidivism?
Well, here there's
not necessarily
a projection bias needed.
But here people might
misunderestimate
how important cues are in
affecting people's utility.
So if it's a case that an
addict, for example-- when
the addict walks by,
like, a liquor store
or when the addict
is talking to friends
who they have been taking
drugs in the past and so on,
that might really increase
people's marginal utility
of using drugs.
So they might get really,
really strong cravings,
and it might be really, really
hard for them to resist.
Now if you know that as an
addict who is recovering,
who's not taking
any drugs currently,
you should at all
cost avoid these cues
because you know you want
to make sure that you're not
exposed to them.
But if you have protection
bias, you might underestimate
the importance of
those cues in affecting
your utility or your
cravings, and so
you might sort of walk
into a bar thinking like,
well, I haven't really
been smoking or drinking
for a long time, so I'm sure
they will be able to resist.
But, of course, then once
you're exposed to these cues,
you will not be able to do
so, and that misprediction
might really then
cause recidivism.
So again, in that
sense, protection bias
is also consistent with that
kind of recidivism due to cues.
Now let me talk very briefly
only about depression.
And the reason being
that we're going
to talk about mental
health in a future lecture.
So depressed individuals
have the tendency
to project the depressed
feelings not only to the future
but also to the past.
And so in particular, the
depressed tend to think about--
depression is the inability
to construct a future.
And in particular, when
someone is depressed,
the past and future are absorbed
entirely by the present,
and people can neither
remember feeling better
nor imagine that they will
feel better in the future.
So that's to say if
the person is really
feeling terrible
right now, they also
think they always have been
feeling terrible in the past,
and they also think
that they will always
feel terrible in the future.
So then life might feel
particularly hopeful
if there's no scope for
future improvements.
And if you think your
life was always that bad,
there's really--
in some cases, people
might think there's really
not much of a reason to live.
And that's, of course,
an extremely dangerous
and difficult or consequential,
potentially, misprediction
because, of course,
depressed people
can get better through therapy
and through drugs and so on.
And often there's also
remission over time.
But if people mispredict that,
they might, for instance, never
seek treatment because they
think, why would I ever seek
treatment if I'm
always feeling terrible
for the rest of my life anyway?
We're going to get back
to that a little bit
when talking about
mental health.
Now, one thing that we have
not really talked about
is how to think about
these different biases.
In particular,
what's the difference
between projection bias
and naive quasi-hyperbolic
discounting?
So both naivety and
quasi-hyperbolic discounting
and projection bias
entail a misprediction.
So as an example, take a
smoker who wants to quit.
The naive quasi-hyperbolic
discounter
overestimates their
future patience.
So that person will sign up
for a commitment contract
to stop smoking and might
fail due to the overestimation
of usefulness of
commitment devices.
That person thinks
that commitments--
the person understands
that she has some--
suppose that's a partially
naive person, which we need.
Otherwise the person
would never sign up
for a commitment contract.
Suppose the person
is partially naive.
The person will sign up for
that commitment contract
thinking that's going to
help them stop smoking,
but the person is
going to underestimate
how bad their
self-control problems are.
So then the person
might fail because they
think their commitment device
is really, really helpful when,
in fact, it's not strong enough.
Now for projection
bias, the person
might underestimate
the influence
of altered future states.
So the person might also sign
up for a commitment contract
to stop smoking
and then might feel
guilty due to the
underestimation of the changes
in future cravings.
That is to say if you are
currently not craving,
you might sign up
for a commitment
contract that would help you
to continue not using drugs.
And you might
underestimate, however,
how bad the cravings
will be in the future
once you see certain
cues or the like.
So again, you might choose
a commitment contract
that is not strong enough
because you mispredict
your future preferences.
In this case, not because
it's in the future,
not because you mispredicting
beta like in case number one
but rather because
you mispredict
how strongly future states
will affect your preferences.
You can also think about
another example, anesthesia
during childbirth.
You can get similar
sort of patterns.
Both naive quasi-hyperbolic
discounting and projection bias
might be able to explain
people's choices there.
In particular, both of
them would potentially
predict preference reversals.
Now, how can we tell projection
bias and naivety regarding beta
apart?
Well, the key part here
is that projection bias
is a state-dependent
misprediction.
So people are more likely
to predict future temptation
to overeat when hungry.
They're more likely
to predict smoking
when you haven't had a
cigarette for a while.
So when people are-- when
the state in the future
is different from
the current state,
people might mispredict
their preferences.
So now a present
bias, in fact, has
nothing to do with the
state, essentially just about
the future versus the present.
So now what do we need?
What kind of variation do we
need to disentangle the two
explanations?
Well, you need
variation in timing
and in particular
variation in states.
So present bias would
say it doesn't really
matter what state you're in.
It doesn't matter whether
you're hungry or not right now.
There's always going
to be a misprediction
between the present
and the future.
And projection bias would very
much say the states matter.
It's a state-dependent
misprediction.
So if you wanted to look
at people's predictions
for the future, present bias or
naivete regarding present bias
would say it doesn't matter
whether you have smoked
or whether you're hungry
right now for your prediction
for the future.
Projection bias would say
it does matter quite a bit.
But then a tricky question
is when should you,
in fact, offer people
commitment devices?
Well, you should probably
offer people commitment devices
if you want them
to choose correct--
if you want people to
make correct choices.
You probably want
to offer people
commitment devices at
times when they're,
in fact, in the same state.
So when somebody
already has cravings,
you want to offer them
a commitment device
because that person
really understands
how it will feel in the future.
If, instead, you offer somebody
a commitment device when
they don't have
cravings, they might
choose that commitment
device, which I guess is good.
But then they might fail
because they mispredict
how strong of a
commitment device
they might need in the future.
OK, so let me then
briefly summarize.
So what did we talk about?
So we talked about
state-dependent preferences.
So preferences
vary systematically
with the underlying states--
for example, hunger.
Food is tastier
when you're hungry.
Going on dates is less
enjoyable while being sick.
Classes are best
when you're rested.
Now, people know that
people's preferences
vary with their states.
They understand that.
If you ask hungry people about
are your preferences different
when you're hungry
versus not, most people
would probably say they want
different types of kinds
of food and the like and
they behave differently
when they're hungry.
However, there are biases
in state-dependent decision
making.
In particular, both
intuition and psychology
suggests that we
fail to appreciate
the extent to which
our preferences change
with the underlying states.
Projection bias is a
specific psychological error
of this type.
People overestimate the extent
to which future tastes resemble
their current tastes, and they
underestimate the influence
that the state has
on their utility,
and that can lead to
systematic misprediction.
I showed you quite
a few applications.
In particular,
addiction and depression
might be the most
consequential applications
of projection bias.
Now there's one more
bias that I told you
I'm going to talk about
very briefly-- again, that's
going to be discussed in
detail in recitation-- which
is called attribution bias.
Now attribution bias in
some sense is very similar,
but it's backward looking.
So what projection bias is the
misprediction of the influence
of future states.
So when you think about the
future, are you going to be--
how are you going to
enjoy a meal depending
on when you're hungry versus
not or burgers versus salad?
How is your future preferences
shaped by future states?
Attribution bias is
instead backward looking.
It's the misprediction of
the influence of past states.
So that's to say-- and I'm
going to sort of define that
briefly--
when judging the
value of a good,
people are overly influenced
by the state in which they
previously consumed it.
Now let me give
you some examples.
And again, then you'll talk
about this more in recitation.
People are more likely to
return to a restaurant when
first trying when hungry.
So if you go to a restaurant
when you're really, really
hungry, you'll think
the food is amazing
while, in fact, it might just
be that you're really, really
hungry.
So when you then come
back to the restaurant,
you might be surprised that,
in fact, it's not that great.
People are also more likely to
negatively rate a movie when
they've seen it while tired.
Well, why is that?
Because the experience
is just not that great,
and then you sort of think the
movie is really not that great.
But, really, it's
just you were tired.
People are also less likely
to recommend a zoo to a friend
if it rained during
the last visit.
Well, it's just the experience
of that zoo is not that great.
Of course, some days it rains
and some days it doesn't.
So you're not going to tell
usually your friend to only go
there when it's sunny.
People are saying the zoo
was just not that much fun.
And perhaps more
relevant for you,
people are more likely to--
or may be more likely to
recommend a class that they
took while well rested.
So a few years ago I was
teaching 1413 at 9:00 AM,
and I got lots of complaints
from students about the class
being way too early.
And I was telling them or trying
to tell them that the class is
really lots of fun.
You may or may not be able to
appreciate that if you really
are tired.
So attribution bias might
sort make you think that--
might attribute some negative
or positive experience
to the actual underlying
quality of the issue
or the good that's being offered
as opposed to, as you should,
to the underlying state.
Again, you're going to talk
more about this in recitation.
Now what's next?
Remember, there is no
class on Monday, April 20.
On Wednesday, April
22, we're going
to talk about gender,
discrimination, and identity.
Please read Heather
Sarson's paper, section one,
just the introduction.
Thank you very much.